australia's one of their biggest banks
is going all in on bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies the commonwealth bank
of australia is the first mainstream
australian bank to offer crypto services
to customers they're going to start a
pilot this year in partnership with
gemiini to allow people to start to
actually interface with these assets
according to finder.com australia has
the third highest rate of crypto
ownership or at 17.8 percent australians
don't play around australia it loves
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies now
commonwealth bank of australia is
massive it is founded in 1911 it's more
than 100 years old it serves almost 16
million customers it employs almost 50
000 people and there are more than 800
000 shareholders with the business the
partnership that they've signed is with
gemini gemini is going to help offer a
crypto exchange and custody services
they've also partnered with chain
analysis to help its compliance team
monitor and mitigate the threat of cyber
crimes they're going to do more than
just bitcoin they have 10 other digital
assets they're going to offer as well
and so why exactly are they doing this
well the commonwealth bank of australia
they said that they believe that much of
this decision is being driven by the
clients the clients are demanding that
they get access to these assets on top
of that other local crypto services are
being offered by square paypal and
revolut which means that they have to
compete with those competitors and so
you get two factions or two groups that
are pulling commonwealth bank of
australia into cryptocurrency you have
your competitors going out and offering
this stuff and so if you want to compete
you have to offer it as well you also
have your clients demanding that they
get access and so we've got these two
quotes here the first coming from the
ceo of btc markets saying nothing that i
know particularly from a bank of this
size enables retail clients to directly
buy crypto through their platform to the
best of my knowledge so it's really
exciting from caroline bowler and then
we have andrew bragg who's a senator for
new south wales who says i am pleased
the tide is turning as digital assets
are mainstreamed for too long banks have
cast aside cryptocurrency as an
illegitimate fringe pursuit
pretty cool and so when we start to look
at this
more and more banks are going to have to
get in the game we see banks here in the
united states starting to talk about it
starting to try to figure out what their
strategy is but to see one of the
largest banks in the country that is the
third most popular for cryptocurrency
say i can no longer sit on the sidelines
i have to participate this is the game
theory playing out
it is inevitable every single financial
institution will have to interface with
these assets they'll have to support
them they'll have to build exchanges and
custody and all sorts of different
services to allow a new generation of
investors who say i do not want the
analog assets i do not want the
electronic q sip assets i want the
digital assets i want bitcoin and crypto
currencies and so naturally what we are
going to watch over the next decade or
so is the mainstream adoption we will go
from about 10 penetration in the world
for people to own bitcoin all the way up
to 85 90
and it'll happen very quickly because
what will occur is large organizations
like this will start to onboard all of
their existing users this bank which is
over a hundred years old has more than
15 million customers
as soon as you start to offer these
services what they're gonna find is that
a small percentage of them start to
adopt the products then a bigger
percentage and a bigger percentage and a
bigger percentage and after five six
seven eight ten years what you're going
to find is that those assets
are going to be in the hands of all of
these customers and so if you are
looking at the industry today when i
first started looking at this stuff in
2016 i literally thought i'd missed it
because i had watched from 2009 at the
creation of bitcoin all the way to 2016
i didn't participate i didn't even pay
attention to it i thought i missed it
but now if you look and there's people
showing up in 2021 they think they've
missed it right they say 2009 all the
way to 2021 more than a decade
but if you look at the actual structure
of the market and you look at who's
coming and you look at how large these
organizations are
they are massive
and they are bringing their customers
and their assets and they are going to
have to blend in and ultimately what
we're going to watch is we're not going
to talk about crypto companies we're not
going to talk about crypto assets it's
just going to be companies and assets
and those companies in those assets
it's just going to be normal similar to
internet companies we don't talk about
internet companies we talk about
companies of course they use the
internet same thing with these
technologies as well john what did you
think when you saw the australian news
cba
massive bank
it serves almost 16 million customers
they have i believe a 24 percent in 2019
they had about 24 um share of the home
lending market and then another 14 of
the business landing market you can see
it there and 27 of the household
deposits it's a massive bank with a lot
of money um this move will help retain i
think the younger customers who want
access to these assets um and it's only
a good move for the industry uh and
giving people access
they ain't gonna be the they ain't gonna
be the last one that's for sure
i think uh when it comes to crypto
specifically whether it's bitcoin or any
of the other 10 digital assets that
they're offering uh people want services
around them at their traditional banks
right and i think uh maybe not the
hardcore people that believe that you
don't need a bank after this sure i get
it but ultimately if this is going to go
super mainstream and it's going to
become the global reserve currency of
the world and get all this adoption and
all this stuff these services are
necessary and i think banks like this
stepping up with 16 million customers is
a step in the right direction and it's
going to be interesting to see over the
next 12 24 36 months who follow suit on
it
the part to me
which i think everyone overlooks
is that it's not just about the numbers
of customers coming in either it's also
that there are major banks now starting
to give the blessing right the the
father-son holy spirit good you're ready
to rock and roll it's kind of like the
etf approval in the united states the
etf approval of the united states sure
there's some capital that flowed but
it's not like 50 billion dollars floated
into those funds it's just the fact that
the sec signed off on it and they
finally said okay this has now reached a
point where we are comfortable with it
in one form or fashion same thing with
these large banks is there is going to
be some portion of the population in
australia who's sitting out because
they're saying hey commonwealth bank of
australia is not in yet but as soon as
they finally say okay we support this
like wealth is good enough for them then
it's good enough for me i trust their
brand i trust them whether you agree
with that they should do that or not
that's where ultimately you get the the
difference or kind of the real impact in
my opinion well these banks also have a
lot of different services and resources
already set up right and it brings that
name and that established uh
institutional name into the space and i
think people trust these banks right um
a lot of people some people don't but a
lot of people do and they're willing to
have them custody their own bitcoin or
their other cryptocurrencies like ether
bitcoin cash litecoin all that stuff um
and i think people are are gonna use
these banks and these banks are gonna
have to shift in the future
what did you think uh joe
no i agree i think uh it's obviously a
massive bank especially in australia so
i think uh anytime you can get someone
of that stature and that kind of
customer base to come on and start
offering these assets and realize that
there's demand for it and that's really
what it is right it's all driven by
customer demand so if you start everyone
starts screaming from the rooftops to
their institutions hey we need these
services we want you to custody our
bitcoin we want you to do lending we
want you to do all this stuff then
they're going to find go find a way to
do it right so uh maybe it's part of
they wanted to be the first ones to do
it maybe it's that they wanted to
appease their customers there's a bunch
of different ways that it could have
gone but i think ultimately this is just
the beginning but these are always the
exciting steps right because the first
people always lead to two three four
five six especially the bigger banks
that are doing it and i think what we'll
see is over those next you know the next
two three years that i mentioned before
we're gonna see a lot more people do
this and a lot more banks follow suit
that's exactly correct that's what cba
said they said it was a growing customer
demand for their products and the fact
that other people um offer these
products like other fintech companies
not traditional banks right so square
paypal uh revolu all these other
companies that that offer some type of
crypto service or crypto could stop
custody um they need to compete
yeah and and to be honest i wouldn't be
surprised if this was uh
the means for a massive customer
acquisition strategy also right because
if you become that bank they're big
obviously where they are currently and
they're the big player there but when
you start thinking about a way to uh
here in the us to acquire customers away
from another bank there's people that
would switch banks happily if you went
over you said hey we're gonna allow you
to custody bitcoin we're gonna allow you
to lend off of it we're gonna do all
these services around your uh your
digital assets i think that the first
banks that end up doing it it's probably
not gonna be the biggest banks that you
might think of right but but the the
medium to the smaller to your guys are
going to do it first because they
realize that the first innovator and the
first mover in that in that category is
going to get a massive tailwind from the
industry